[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui le traité mieux
start dernière accorde au contrôle des
armements entre la russie et les etats
unis ils arrivent à échéance en février
2021 et son renouvellement est
aujourd'hui très incertain alors comment
se présente l'expiration prochaine de ce
traité new start
à moins d'un an de l'expiration du
traité le nul tire la sonnette d'alarmé
en appelant la russie et les etats unis
à prolonger cet accord cette inquiétude
semble être partagée par le royaume-uni
la france et la chine qui veulent le
renouvellement de new start sans
pourtant envisagé d'y adhérer eux mêmes
la russie quant à elle se dit prête à
prolonger l'effet du traité sans
conditions préalables
de son côté l'administration trump
hésite entre le renouvellement de
l'accord existant et la conclusion d'un
nouveau traité global sur la limitation
des armements selon la maison blanche la
décision pourrait être annoncée courant
2020 cette polémique sur le new star
arrive après la sortie des états unis de
l'autre traité de contrôle sur les
armements russes aux américains le fmi
qui portait sur les missiles à courte et
moyenne portée après avoir testé un
nouveau modèle interdit par cet accord
washington dévoile ses projets de
déployer ces dispositifs
en asie la russie promet d'y répondre et
annoncent travailler sur de nouveaux
types de missiles de courte et moyenne
portée
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur le rapport de force
actuel en matière d'armement nucléaire
c'est le bit aujourd'hui huit pays
possède de facto des armes nucléaires
les états unis la russie le royaume uni
la france la chine l'inde le pakistan et
la corée du nord les deux premières
détiennent plus de 90% du stock mondial
ensuite viennent la france la grande
bretagne et la chine qui ont un arsenal
beaucoup plus modeste soit 5 7 % du
stock nucléaire mondiale le reste est
réparti entre l'inde le pakistan et la
corée du nord
la quantité d'armes nucléaires dans le
monde est limitée par le traité de non
prolifération nucléaire en vigueur
depuis 1970 ce document distingue cinq
états qui ont le droit de détenir ce
type d'armement les etats unis la russie
le royaume-uni la france et la chine
par ce traité il s'engage à ne pas
transférer d'armes ainsi qu'à ne pas
aider d'autres tas en fabriquer ou en
acquérir
à ce jour 191 états sont membres du tnp
pourtant quatre états n'ont pas signé
cet accord il s'agit du second du sud de
l'inde du pakistan et d'israël
ce dernier pourrait en fait détenir des
armes nucléaires les suspicions pèsent
sur l'état hébreu depuis les années 80
mais tel-aviv évite de commenter
l'existence de ses capacités nucléaires
le premier et le seul état à ce jour à
s'être retiré du traité de non
prolifération nucléaire et la corée du
nord
trois ans après cette décision clôt
langue en 2006 annonce avoir mené un
essai nucléaire
le compte à rebours est donc lancé il
reste moins d'un an jusqu'à l'expiration
du traité new start signé il y a dix ans
par la russie et les etats unis
il est actuellement le seul instrument
légal et mettant la course aux armements
entre les deux plus grandes puissances
nucléaires
le nude tire la sonnette d'alarmé en
appelant les parties à négocier le
renouvellement de l'accord moscou se dit
prêt au dialogue
de son côté washington veut d'abord
s'assurer que la prolongation satisfasse
à deux conditions
l'extinction du traité aux nouveaux
armements russes et l'inclusion d'autres
pays en premier lieu cela concerne la
chine qui selon le pentagone développe
rapidement son arsenal nucléaire pour sa
part pékin appelle à sauver l'accord
mais
refuge malgré tout d'évoquer une
éventuelle adhésion de sa part une
situation plus qu'alarmante à laquelle
vient s'ajouter le retrait américain du
traité et fait ni l'autre pilier
important de la sécurité mondiale en
2019 à peine les etats-unis ont-ils
dénoncé cet accord que le développement
de nouveaux armements à recommencer
partout dans le monde
alors comment l'expiration du new start
peut être bouleverser le rapport de
force sur l'échiquier mondial
quels sont les points faibles du traité
en vigueur enfin comment la chine
explique t'elle sont roger de l'adhésion
à l'accord pour répondre à ces questions
nous rejoignons au général dominique
trinquant ancien chef de la mission
française auprès de l'onu général 30 ans
bonjour bonjour
la russie est prête à prolonger le
traité new star sans conditions
préalables cependant ce n'est pas le cas
des états unis l'administration trump se
montre sceptique et à son égard pourquoi
selon vous alors l'administration trump
à deux sujets majeurs aujourd'hui le
premier étant de la campagne électorale
je rappelle que ce traité est un
héritage de l'ère obama
or monsieur trump se place en
contrepoint de l'ère obama est donc dans
sa campagne électorale il est moins
important qu'il montre que tous les
traités internationaux et était un aveu
de faiblesse des états unis et que lui
est un homme fort c'est le premier point
le deuxième point c'est que plus
technique c'est que les états unis
pensent que la russie est en train de
contourner le traité en requalifiant en
ayant des armes de plus grande qualité
est donc ça n'est pas tant un nombre de
têtes que plutôt une qualité des têtes
qui compte voilà les deux raisons pour
lesquelles je pense les etats unis
aujourd'hui ne souhaite pas renouveler
cet accord qui arrive à terme en 2021
donc l'année prochaine et qui pourrait
être renouvelée sans aucun problème pour
cinq ans pourtant le congrès américain
et même les républicains appellent
donald trump a prolongé cet accord
pourquoi oui parce que dans l'accord il
ya plusieurs choses la première chose
c'est bien sûr la limitation en volume
mais c'est aussi la capacité
d'inspection et
échange et c'est ce qui gêne beaucoup
une grande partie de l'administration
américaine parce qu'ils pensent que s'il
n'y a plus d'accord il n'y aura plus de
vérifications et s'il n'y a plus de
vérifications on n'est pas en mesure de
s'assurer de des armes dont peuvent
disposer l'autre tenant de l'accord donc
si vous voulez c'est pas seulement une
question de plafond mais une question de
capacité d'information vis-à-vis des des
armes détenues par l'autre partie
prenante à l'accord
en fait à quoi servira la fabrication
d'armes nucléaires au delà de la limite
fixée par le new start 1550 ogives et
800 vecteur ne sont ils pas suffisant
pour la capacité de dissuasion dans le
monde
oui vous avez raison c'est parfaitement
suffisant il faut noter d'ailleurs que
cet accord new start a permis une
réduction importante par un vecteur de 4
ou 5 à peu près des vecteurs qui
existait donc vous avez raison
aujourd'hui le volume est suffisant
le problème c'est la qualité lorsque
vous avez des missiles hyper véloce
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont à dix ou vingt
fois la vitesse du son
vous arrivez à contourner les défenses
adverses et donc vous avez un avantage
majeur
donc je pense que c'est plus sur la
qualité des vecteurs que sur le nombre
des vecteurs que l'accord doit
aujourd'hui sa tâche et merci beaucoup
général tran quand nous allons
poursuivre notre analyse mais nous vous
retrouverons en fin d'émission pour plus
de détails sur la question merci
beaucoup
l'expiration très prochaine du traité
new start inquiète de plus en plus le nu
le 4 février 2020 le secrétaire général
de l'organisation tire la sonnette
d'alarmé
nous disons aux états unis et à la
fédération de russie qu'il est essentiel
de renouveler le traité new start
car si le new start se termine sans
renouvellement ce n'est pas seulement la
question de la limitation des armements
mais ce sont tous les mécanismes de
contrôle qui serait remise en cause
alors pourquoi cet accord est il si
importante pour la sécurité mondiale
et bien parce que c'est l'unique accord
sur la réduction des armes nucléaires
encore en vigueur conclus entre la
russie
les etats unis les deux plus grandes
puissances nucléaires signé en avril
2010 pour une période de dix ans il
prévoit la limitation à 800 le nombre de
lanceurs nucléaires stratégiques
déployées ou non le nombre de missiles
balistiques intercontinentaux missile
mer-sol balistique et bombardiers lourds
déployés ne doit pas dépasser 700 unités
en outre les termes du traité les mythes
à 1550 le nombre d'ogives nucléaires
déployées par chaque pays enfin de
vérifier le respect de ces accords les
parties se réserve le droit de mener des
inspections sur place chez le pays
partenaire
théoriquement ce traité expire en
février 2021
pourtant une prolongation de cinq ans
est possible en cas d'accord des deux
parties afin de satisfaire aux limites
fixées par le traité les pistes se sont
donné huit ans à l'arrivée de la date
limite en 2018 la russie et les
etats-unis déclarent chacun à son tour
avoir rempli les conditions de ce traité
cependant moscou n'est pas complètement
satisfait de la mise en oeuvre de
l'accord côté américain selon le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
washington ne prend pas en compte une
partie des armes stratégiques qu'ils
considèrent comme rééquiper il s'agit de
cinquante six lanceurs se marrant tu
trahis de n2 et quarante et un
bombardier lourd b 5 en 2 h qui ne
peuvent plus selon washington être
utilisées pour lancer des missiles
nucléaires la réussite de son côté
déclaré ne pas être en mesure de le
vérifier et insiste que ces lanceurs
doivent être comptés tout comme
d'ailleurs les quatre silos de lancement
que les états unis ont requalifié dans
une catégorie non prévue par le traité
celles de stylos d'entraînement selon la
diplomatie russe au total washington
dépasse le nombre des armes stratégiques
autorisé par le traité de son une unité
cependant en dépit de tous ces
désaccords la russie se dit être prête à
prolonger le traité new start sans même
avancé de conditions préalables
je tiens à réaffirmer la position de la
fédération de russie la russie est prête
à immédiatement dès que possible sans
aucune condition préalable bien
prolonger le traité new start
de leur côté les états unis ne se presse
pas de répondre sceptique à l'égard de
cet accord la limite
a sion trump promet de prendre une
décision dans l'année en cours en
attendant washington avance sa vision de
l'accord renouvelé qui devrait
résolument satisfaire deux conditions la
première c'est l'extinction du traité à
d'autres pays il s'agit avant tout de la
chine selon l'administration 30 pékin
développe activement son arsenal
nucléaire et ne peut plus rester un
simple observateur dans les questions de
réduction des armes nucléaires à
l'échelle mondiale ensuite washington
insistent pour que l'application de
l'accord s'étendent aux nouveaux
armements russes
une catégorie qui pourrait comprendre
selon certains médias les missiles
hypersonique russe avant garde et qu'il
gèle la diplomatie russe quand elle se
dit prête à rechercher un compromis même
sur la question très sensible de
nouveaux armements
les américains s'intéressent à nos
nouvelles armes nous avons déjà
mentionné que nos forces armées sont
prêtes à examiner une partie de ces
nouvelles armes
du moins avant de garder sarmates dans
le contexte des critères du traité
parallèlement à la prolongation de
l'accord donald trump envisage une autre
option conclure un nouveau traité global
sur la limitation des armements
mais faut-il néanmoins pour cela
enterrer le new start un des principaux
piliers de la sécurité mondiale au
demeurant
l'accord actuel n'est pas exempt
d'imperfections
l'une d'entre elles est le potentiel de
réarmement le new start limite à 1550 le
nombre d'ogives nucléaires déployées
seul problème il n'y a aucune limite
pour le nombre d'ogives n'ont déployé un
vide juridique qui laisse la possibilité
de les stocker pour ensuite déployé en
cas d'urgence l'autre problème qui se
pose dans le cadre du traité en vigueur
et celui du rééquipement afin de
satisfaire aux limites fixées par le
traité le pays signataires peut déclarer
qu'une partie de son armement et
rééquiper donc
or le régime de contrôle de l'accord en
pratique pourtant il est quasi
impossible de vérifier si larmes dites
rééquiper correspond pas vraiment aux
conditions fixées dans le document
malgré ces quelques défauts au congrès
américain les voix se lève pour sauver
l'accord en vigueur au moins trois
projets de loi appelant à la
prolongation du new start ont été
introduites dans le congrès pendant
l'année dernière aujourd'hui la pression
sur le président le fait que se
renforcer
maintenant qu'il ne reste qu'un an avant
l'expiration du new start
nous exhortons le président trump à
conclure un accord avec le président
poutine pour prolonger le traité de cinq
ans alors comment l'expiration très
prochaine du new start peut-elle avoir
un impact sur la sécurité mondiale et
comment les autres puissances du club
nucléaire a réagi stèle à l'absence de
compromis sur le renouvellement de cet
accord
la réponse après la pause le traité new
start arrivera à échéance dans un an si
aucun compromis n'est pas atteindre très
prochainement
il n'y aura plus aucun instrument légal
restreignant le potentiel des missiles
nucléaires de la russie et des états
unis
une première depuis les années 60
lorsque les premiers pas vers le
désarmement avait été franchie en 1962
la crise des missiles de cuba éclate en
pleine guerre froide
les tensions entre le res s et les
etats-unis sont à leur apogée
les deux pays s'accusent mutuellement de
déployer des missiles nucléaires près de
leur frontière un conflit ouvert entre
les deux superpuissances est à leur
évitait de justesse
dès 1963 à les états unis et l'urss
commence à négocier sur le contrôle des
armements nucléaires
c'est le début de la période connue sous
le nom de détente en 1968 le traité sur
la non prolifération des armes
nucléaires est signé par les états unis
le res s et le royaume uni tous
détenteurs de l'armé nucléaire
ils s'accordent à ne pas livrer de
matériel aux autres pays non dotés de
l'armé nucléaire
à l'époque car entre pays se joignent à
ce traité est à ce jour 180 aux états
sont membres du tnp en 1969
moscou et washington entamé une série de
négociations bilatérales plus connu sous
le nom de salt
après près de trois ans de pourparlers
le président américain richard nixon et
le secrétaire général du parti
communiste
leonid brejnev signe salt 1 le 26 mai
c'est le premier traité à freiner à
course aux armements nucléaires en
limitant la fabrication d'armes
stratégiques et de l'installation des
rampes de lancement pour cinq ans de
plus il comprend un traité abm qui
limite le déploiement du système
antimissile balistique à un site de
chaque côté seul un expert en 1977 est
remplacée par celle de deux ans 1979
son principal objectif est la limitation
du nombre de vecteurs stratégiques à
2400 pour chaque pays pourtant fin 1979
les soviétiques interviennent en
afghanistan et les états unis décident
de ne pas ratifier salt 2 il sera tout
de même respecté par les deux parties au
même moment les tensions de la guerre
froide refont surface
c'est le début de la crise des
euromissiles les soviétiques déploie des
missiles de portée intermédiaire ss
vents pouvant atteindre l'europe l'asie
et le moyen orient
le temps réplique à l'install en europe
des missiles pershing
dans ce contexte tendu les deux
puissances tentent tant bien que mal de
continuer les négociations sur le
désarmement nucléaire
c'est l'arrivée au pouvoir de mikhaël
gorbatchev qui contribuent au
réchauffement des relations entre les
deux pays
il signe le 8 décembre 1987 le fmi ce
traité vise à éliminer les missiles à
portée intermédiaire et à courte portée
et ce pour une durée est limitée à
quelques mois de la dissolution de
l'urss moscou et washington signent en
1991 start 1 qui fait suite au traité
salt 1 1 et 2 c'est le premier texte qui
réduit les arsenaux nucléaires des deux
puissances
les têtes nucléaires passe de dix mille
à 6000 pour chaque état de plus et
limitent à 1600 le nombre de leurs
vecteurs après la chute de l'urss les
états unis et la russie
si start 2 le 3 janvier 1993
il prévoit la réduction des têtes
nucléaires américaines à 3500 est celle
de la russie à 3000 pourtant un 2002 la
russie se retire finalement de start 2
suite au retrait des etats-unis du
traité abm la même année les présidents
george w bush et vladimir poutine
s'ils sortent le 24 mai 2002 ils
prévoient de réduire leurs arsenaux
nucléaires des deux tiers en dix ans le
5 décembre 2009
start i expire il est remplacé par start
iii ou new start le 8 avril 2010 c'est
le dernier accord bilatéral russe
américain sur le désarmement nucléaire
ils exigent une plus importante
réduction du nombre de têtes et de
vecteurs nucléaires
le texte prévoit également une
vérification de la mise en oeuvre du
traité par un régime d'inspection
conjointe l'arrivée de donald trump à la
maison blanche va bouleverser ce rapport
de force
les etats unis se retire officiellement
du effet ni le 2 août 2019
estimant ce traité obsolète alors qu'est
les deux pays s'accusent mutuellement
d'avoir violé le fmi moscou souhaite
tout de même ouvrir de nouvelles
négociations afin d'y apporter plus de
précisions néanmoins les états unis
refusent ce qui ouvre la voie au
développement de nouveaux missiles
apporter course et intermédiaires
dernier accord limitant les arsenaux
russe et américain toujours en vigueur
le new start est un traité essentiel aux
yeux de la communauté internationale
pourtant si la maison blanche hésitent à
accepter une simple prolongation sans
inclure deux
le parti sait que l'arsenal nucléaire
mondial n'est pas seulement répartis
entre washington et moscou
si les deux puissances abrite à elle
seule 90 % des ogives nucléaires dans le
monde
d'autres membres du club nucléaire ne
sont pas à négliger la chine l'inde et
le pakistan annoncent ces dernières
années l'extension constante de leurs
arsenaux
de plus les experts militaires
américains dénoncent le manque de
transparence sur l'arsenal chinois
évalué à 2 190 e gif ce chiffre pourrait
être en réalité trois fois plus élevé à
atteindre vers 2025
deux mille trois cents à deux mille
têtes nucléaires les anciennes
puissances nucléaires que sont la france
et la grande bretagne ont un arsenal
plus restreint mais tout aussi
destructeurs plus récemment l'arrivée de
la corée du nord dans ce club pèse aussi
dans l' équilibre mondial plus d'armes
nucléaires est de nouveau acteur
stratégique pour les etats-unis cela
signifie forcément un nouvel accord dans
lequel il voudrait voir figurer la chine
la russie elle regarde aussi du côté de
la grande-bretagne et de la france
pourtant selon la diplomatie russe et de
puissants sont d'accord pour prolonger
l'accord sans pour autant et adhérer la
grande bretagne et la france sont
auparavant entreprises certains efforts
ni latéraux de réduction mais ne
souhaite pas continuer ce processus dans
le cadre d'un accord quant à la chine
elle refuse de rejoindre un éventuel
nouvel accord trilatéral dénonçant des
tentatives américaines de renvoyer la
balle
si les états unis sont vraiment
préoccupés par la stabilité stratégique
internationale ils doivent cesser de
saper l'équilibré stratégique et la
stabilité dans le monde
cesser de jouer la carte de la
compétition de pouvoir et la
confrontation et protéger l'ordre
existant et le système de contrôle des
armements et de la non prolifération
si le traité new start n'est pas
prolongé rien arrêterez une nouvelle
course aux armements entre moscou et
washington
une situation dont on est d'ailleurs
plus très loin avec la fin du traité et
fait ni moins d'un mois après leur
retrait officiel les états unis teste un
nouveau missile auparavant interdit de
plus il se presse pour annoncer des
projets de déploiement de missiles de
moyenne portée en asie notamment pour
contrer la chine quand on possède en
grande quantité une manne à vent
soudaine qui provoque l'ire de pékin
la russie promet également
d'y répondre et met en garde contre un
éventuel déploiement de missiles
américains en europe
en réponse son retrait américain des
faits ni moscou annonce aussi travaillé
sur deux nouveaux types de missiles de
courte et moyenne portée et qui sont
redoutables
parmi eux le missile hypersonique russe
de dernière génération qui pourrait
atteindre une cible à plusieurs milliers
de kilomètres en seulement quelques
minutes sur fond de tension croissante
et une possible expiration du new star
d'autres acteurs mondiaux commencent à
repenser leur propre sécurité dans un
cadre autonome emmanuel macron lui est
par exemple revenu à l'idée d'une europe
de défense en appelant les 27 à une plus
grande coordination militaire redevenir
le terrain de la confrontation des
puissances nucléaires non européenne ne
serait pas acceptable
en tout cas je ne l'acceptent pas je
souhaite que se développe un dialogue
stratégique avec nos partenaires
européens qui sont prêts sur le rôle de
la dissuasion nucléaire française dans
notre sécurité collective
le démantèlement du système de contrôle
des armements place en effet l'europe au
coeur des frictions potentiel cependant
si le possèdent au moins une force de
dissuasion pour se protéger qu'en est il
du reste du monde
en effet les tensions entre les
puissances nucléaires cours dans
plusieurs parties du globe
rappelons nous par exemple du conflit
toujours en cours entre l'inde et le
pakistan autour de la souveraineté sur
le cachemire au moyen-orient également
israël est soupçonné de disposer de
l'armé nucléaire
dès lors ses actions militaires contre
des cibles iraniennes et syriennes
laisse craindre des escalades aux
conséquences potentielles désastreuse de
son côté la corée du nord multiplie des
essais nucléaires attisant les tensions
dans la région
dans quelle mesure la fin du new start
va-t-elle rompre l'équilibré militaire
mondiale déjà fragile est il encore
possible d'éviter la perte du dernier
garde-fous dans la nouvelle course aux
armements pour mieux comprendre les
enjeux du traité ue star nous revenons
vers général de mick trinquant ancien
chef de la mission française auprès de
l'onu général trinquant quel est votre
avis sur la proposition de donald trump
d'élaborer un nouvel accord sur le
contrôle des armements et inclure
d'autres pays par exemple la chine n'est
ce pas la même situation qu'avec
l'accord f
ni beaucoup de propositions au début
mais en fin de compte le traité était
terminée non en fait si vous voulez
lorsque les accords avaient été les
grands accords nucléaires avaient été
traités il se traitait directement entre
la russie et les etats-unis qui étaient
les deux puissances majeures
à eux seuls ils disposent de 92% des
armes nucléaires à disposition dans le
monde
mais depuis il y a une puissance qui a
monté qui est la chine et on sait que
les états unis pensent qu'aujourd'hui la
menace majeure c'est la chine car la
chine est très très loin des volumes
détenu actuellement par la russie et par
les états unis puisque on pense que les
états unis et la russie ont chacun à peu
près mille cinq cents ogives
alors que la russie en aurait même pas
six ans donc nous sommes loin de là mais
on sait que la la chine avance à très
grands pas va très très vite et donc
c'est l'inquiétude des états unis de
voir un traité qui ne concernerait que
les anciennes puissances nucléaires et
non pas la nouvelle qui est la chine et
qui pour eux est l'enjeu majeur des
années à venir
est-ce que ça serait aussi selon vous la
préoccupation de la russie d'inclure la
chine dans le nouveau traité alors la
russie n'en parle pas du tout mais je
crois que la russie a intérêt à se
préoccuper de ce sujet là globalement je
le dis souvent la russie à un choix
c'est de se rapprocher en particulier de
l'europe ou de se faire manger par la
chine et dans le cas nucléaire c'est la
même chose
à force de ne pas regarder la menace
chinoise
celle ci peut évoluer comme ça a été
dans le cas commercial ou pendant très
longtemps tout le monde a dit il faut
aider la chine et à force d'aider la
chine elle est devenue quasiment la
première puissance au monde et bien dans
le domaine nucléaire cela pourrait être
la même chose mais pour l'instant
aujourd'hui la chine la france et le
royaume-uni appelle moscou et washington
à prolonger le traité mais pékin ne veut
pas s'y associer
paris/londres non plus et si l'on en
croit l'ambassadeur russe auprès des
organisations internationales à vienne
pourquoi une telle contradiction alors
la contradiction relève simplement du
problème de la prolongation de l'accord
ou de la négociation d'un nouvel accord
pour négocier un nouvel accord il va
falloir beaucoup de temps surtout si on
veut inclure la chine etc la chine n'a
pas du tout l'intention de s'y intégrer
actuellement donc la position actuelle
en particulier de la france et de dire
il faut prolonger l'accord en question
pour cinq ans et ensuite on se donnera
le temps peut-être de négocier un nouvel
accord
alors maintenant l'inclusion de la
france en particulier permettez moi de
parler pour mon pays
dans cet accord n'a pas grande
signification la france et le président
de la république en a parlé il n'ya pas
longtemps à l'école de guerre a parlé de
la diffusion dispose d'à peine 300
ogives
donc c'est peanuts si j'ose dire à
prendre un terme américains vis-à-vis
des arsenaux russe et américain donc la
position c'est bien reconduire l'accord
actuel de façon à stabiliser à continuer
à échanger sur ces arsenaux nucléaires
et essayer d'une façon ou d'une autre
dans un accord ultérieur d'inclure la
chine qui dans cinq ans in ça ne fait
aucun doute devra faire partie d'un
accord
dernière question la fin du trajet new
start signifiera tel le début de la
nouvelle course aux armements nucléaires
au bien les capacités des états unis et
des autres ne sont pas comparables
si c'est vraiment une course mais la
course elle est entre les etats-unis et
la russie et la cour je le dis elle est
d'abord qualitative les derniers
missiles dévoilé par la russie le
vanguard qui est arrivé
un missile extrêmement véloce contourne
la la protection que les américains on
peut mieux peut plus mettre en place
donc si vous voulez je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on ait pu dans la
multiplication des des vecteurs
nucléaires
on est plutôt dans le changement de
qualité de ses vecteurs nucléaires
et là effectivement il ya il ya un
danger réel
à un moment donné ne connaissant pas
n'ayant pas suffisamment d'informations
sur les systèmes en place de pouvoir à
aller à l'escaladé des puissances
nucléaires en particulier russe et
américain merci beaucoup général
trinquant d'avoir apporté votre
éclairage au rappel général dominique
trinquant était l'invité aujourd'hui de
notre émission ancien chef de la mission
française auprès de l'onu
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]